So one thing I want to emphasize in this part of the lecture is that
the basic element we want to be able to do analysis on most of
the time in a 3D scene is rays of light.
And you want to be able to use a rays of light to
be able to extract information.
So here's a beautiful image of a sun that actually if you see this image,
basically all of the rays of light are coming in.
And we want to be able to kind of model a lot more information about how rays of
light from this light source are hitting different parts of a scene.
And, of course, it's because of the phenomenon of this being hit
these tree branches being hit, and us being able to see it,
that kind of gives us the more visual feel of the scene.
So we've looked at previously, and
we've talked about the whole concept that basically an image is a 2D area of
pixels and that's how we actually capture a 3D scene into a 2D image.
But we want to remember that the fundamental primitives at least in the whole
analysis of a picture of computational photography process is rays, you want to
be able to be able to look at information that's coming and hitting the scene.
And then, of course getting reflected and we want to be able to capture as
much information from the environment based on that illumination and
the rays that are hitting the scene.
One of the things that's important when you start thinking about rays of light
is that basically they follow a path from the source to the scene.
So therefore, we can start using things like geometry of the rays of light to be
able to extract information about what the scene is like.
And more importantly, what we are interested in is how we can actually use
computation, that can control all parameters of how the optics and
the sensor, that is, the way the process of illumination goes,
the rays of light, to go through optics, to the sensor that actually allows us
to generate those pixels, that we can do image processing on.
So, one of the important things for us to remember now is that we want to be
able to use computation, to control how the illumination,
which would then create the rays of light, that would be then controlled again
with the optics to create information on a sensor that would generate the pixels
that we actually will be doing processing on to be able to generate an image.